>>> HE'S GOING TO HAVE TO
CONSIDER RESIGNING.
HE'S GOT TWO CHOICES, ONE HE CAN
TRY TO POLITICAL RIDE IT OUT,
WE'VE SEEN THAT HAPPEN IN
WASHINGTON D.C.
OR HE CAN TAKE THE TOUGHER
CHOICE, WHICH I THINK, LOOK, OWN
EVERY LIE THAT HE'S MADE,
APOLOGIZE TO EVERYONE AND ANYONE
FOR AS LONG AS IT TAKES.
>> SO THAT WAS THE OUTGOING
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN KEVIN
BRADY, NOT HOLDING BACK WHAT HE
THINKS ABOUT CONGRESSMAN ELECT
GEORGE SANTOS WHAT HE SHOULD DO
AFTER HIS WEB OF LIES WERE
EXPOSE CRICKETS FROM THE
HOUSE GOP LEADERSHIP.
SCRU
SCRUTINY LOOMING OVER THIS, THE
LONG LIST OF LIES, INTENSIFYING
AS WELL AS STATE AND FEDERAL
INVESTIGATORS CONDUCT SEPARATE
INVESTIGATIONS.
JOINING US MAGGIE HABERMAN,
ERROL LEWIS.
AS I WAS OFF THIS IS THE ONLY
THING I PAID ATTENTION TO.
THIS IS WHAT EVERYBODY IS
TALKING TO.
HAPPY NEW YEAR TO YOU.
MY ONE QUESTION, HOW DID THIS
HAPPEN?
>> WE'RE ALL USED TO SEE PUBLIC
OFFICIALS WHO SHAVE THE TRUTH,
LIE, AND SO FORTH AND SO ON.
THIS IS A WHOLE OTHER DIMENSION,
A DIFFERENT ORDER OF MAGNITUDE
WHERE HE INVENTED EVERYTHING
FROM HIS NAME TO -- ALMOST
EVERYTHING, HIS WORK LIFE,
EDUCATION LIFE, HIS MOTHER'S
LIFE, GRANDPARENTS' LIFE.
ALL COMPLETELY INVENTED.
IT'S UNUSUAL TO RUN INTO
SOMEBODY LIKE THAT, AND WE DON'T
HAVE A SYSTEM, EVEN THE INFORMAL
PARTS OF OUR SYSTEM, MEDIA
VETTING, OPPOSITION RESEARCH,
PARTY MECHANISMS AND SO FORTH WE
DON'T HAVE MECHANISMS FOR
CATCHING OR TRAPPING SOMETHING
LIKE THAT BECAUSE IT DOESN'T
HAPPEN.
>> AT THE SAME TIME USUALLY
THERE'S ONE MECHANISM THAT WILL
CATCH SOMETHING.
THERE'S THE MEDIA, THE RIVAL
OPPONENTS, THE NATIONAL
REPUBLICANS AND LOCAL
REPUBLICANS, I DON'T THINK
THAT'S GETTING TALKED ENOUGH
ABOUT, AND THAT'S REPUBLICANS
WHO SAW THE GUY RUN TWO YEARS
AGO, WHAT WERE THEY AWARE OF,
WILLING TO TOLERATE IN THE HOPES
TO SEE HOW FAR IT WOULD GO IN
THIS CLIMATE, THE OTHER THING
WE'VE NEVER SEEN IS SILENCE LIKE
THIS FROM LEADERSHIP.
AS YOU SEE KEVIN McCARTHY IN HIS
BATTLE TO STAY ALIVE AND BECOME
THE NEXT SPEAKER HE HAS BEEN
INCREDIBLY QUIET IN PART BECAUSE
HE NEEDS EVERY VOTE.
NO REASON TO BELIEVE THAT SANTOS
IS NOT GOING TO GET SEATED, I
BELIEVE HE WILL GET SEATED AND
THE INVESTIGATIONS CONTINUE.
>> HE HAS TO.
>> THERE'S NO MECHANISM IN THE
HOUSE FOR GETTING RID OF HIM.
THAT'S SOMETHING PEOPLE HAVEN'T
UNDERSTOOD.
AND THERE COULD BE A LAW
ENFORCEMENT EFFORT TO GET RID OF
HIM AND I THINK WE'LL SEE
FOCUSES ON THAT, BUT I CAN'T
REMEMBER ANY TIME WHERE THERE
HAS BEEN EVEN A FRACTION OF THIS
AND LEADERSHIP HAS BEEN SO QUIET
IN EITHER PARTY.
>> THIS IS SOME OF THE QUIETEST.
AS YOU SAY, THE CONSTITUTION
SAYS IF YOU'RE 25 YEARS OLD,
YOU'VE BEEN IN THE COUNTRY AS A
CITIZEN FOR 7 YEARS AND YOU LIVE
IN THE STATE, THAT'S IT.
AND THE HOUSE DOESN'T GET TO
PICK AND CHOOSE WHO GETS TO
STAY.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
BUT THERE'S ALSO JUST WHAT'S
RIGHT AND WHAT'S WRONG.
AND WHEN YOU SPEAK UP WHEN
SOMETHING IS SO WRONG, HE TOOK
AMERICAN TRAGEDIES LIKE 9/11,
LIKE THE PULSE NIGHTCLUB
SHOOTING, AND USED THEM TO HIS
BENEFIT TO GAIN SYMPATHY AND GET
ELECTED.
I WONDER WHAT YOU THINK IT SAYS
ABOUT OUR CULTURE OF LYING AND
ACCEPTING LIES.
>> IN THE OLD DAYS, POPPY, HE
WOULD HAVE -- DON'T YOU THINK HE
WOULD HAVE --
>> THERE WOULD HAVE BEEN MORE
SHAME.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> IT'S DEEP IN AMERICAN
CULTURE, THINK ABOUT A PLAY LIKE
"THE MUSIC MAN" THE CON MAN WHO
COMINGS TO TOWN AND TELLS
EVERYBODY WHAT THEY WANT TO
HEAR, IN THIS CASE YOU HAVE THIS
GUY, YOU LIKE PETS I HAVE A PET
CHARITY THAT SAVED 3,000
ANIMALS.
HE DOESN'T.
AT ONE POINT HE'S THE SON OF A
BLACK FATHER.
EVERY PIECE OF VOTING SUPPORT HE
CAN PICK UP.
>> HE'S NOT A JEW, HE'S JEWISH.
>> DO YOU HYPHEN IT?
>> WE SHOULD GET USED TO THE
IDEA THAT THESE CREATURES EXIST,
THE PEOPLE WHO COME TO TOWN AND
TELL EVERYBODY WHAT THEY WANT TO
HEAR AND WE HAVE TO FIGURE IT
OUT.
WE HAVE A SYSTEM THAT THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM IS CRANKING UP.
WE HAVE AN ATTORNEY GENERAL,
FEDERAL PROSECUTORS LOOKING INTO
HIM.
THE NASSAU COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY SAYING IF ANY CRIMES
WERE COMMITTED WE'LL PROSECUTE.
THE MEDIA IS RAMPING UP.
IT'S GOING TO HAVE TO CATCH UP
WITH THE POLITICAL SYSTEM AND,
YOU KNOW, IN ABOUT 24 MONTHS AT
THE LATEST THE VOTERS WILL HAVE
A CHANCE TO FIX IT.
>> THE CULTURE OF LYING, THIS IS
SOMETHING OBVIOUS TRUMP
NORMALIZED.
SAY WHAT YOU WANT, LIE ABOUT
WHATEVER, AND JUST DOUBLE,
TRIPLE, QUADRUPLE DOWN AND
REFUSE TO BACK DOWN.
IT MAY WORK FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE,
USUALLY JUST WORKED FOR TRUMP.
DO YOU THINK IT'S GOING TO WORK
FOR GEORGE SANTOS?
>> HE'S GOING TO BE SEATED AND
THEN WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS WITH
THE INVESTIGATIONS.
ERROL IS RIGHT, TO MAKE THE
POINT, LYING IS NOT NEW IN
AMERICAN CULTURE AND POLITICS.
>> TO THIS EXTENT --
>> NOT TO THIS EXTENT.
I CAN'T THINK OF A PRECEDENT FOR
THIS.
I HAVE COVERED POLITICIANS WHO
HAVE LIED, LIED TO ME, TO
VOTERS, PADDED THEIR RESUMES,
WE'VE NEVER SEEN SOMETHING LIKE
THIS.
I DON'T THINK YOU WOULD HAVE
SEEN SILENCE LIKE THIS AS YOU
HAVE PRE-TRUMP.
I DON'T THINK YOU WOULD HAVE
SEEN THIS LEVEL OF SORT OF JUST
RIDE IT OUT AND SEE WHAT
HAPPENS, BUT EVERYTHING IS ABOUT
PARTY TRIBALISM NOW AND THAT'S A
LOT OF WHAT WE'RE SEEING.
>> THIS IS THE THING THAT
EVERYBODY IS TALKING ABOUT.
GIVE US MORE TIME WITH THE
SEGMENT.
YOU ARE A MEMBER -- YOU COVER
POLITICS IN NEW YORK.
>> YES.
>> I LIVE OUT ON LONG ISLAND AND
THE LEADER ON LONG ISLAND DID
THIS.
COVERED THIS STORY.
WHAT HAPPENED TO THE LOCAL MEDIA
THAT IT DIDN'T CATCH ALL OF
THESE LIES OR WERE NOT
INTERESTED ENOUGH?
I DON'T KNOW.
YOU TELL ME.
>> I ASKED THAT VERY QUESTION.
THERE ARE -- THERE'S AT LEAST A
PAPER I BELIEVE IN OYSTER BAY
THAT DID CATCH SOME OF THIS AND
PUBLISHED SOME OF THIS.
BUT THE WAY THINGS WORK, IT'S
GOT TO BE SORT OF MOVED UP THE
CHAIN YOU KNOW, I MEAN, I'M
BASED IN NEW YORK CITY, SPECTRUM
NEWS, A SMALL PIECE OF THIS
DISTRICT IS IN NEW YORK CITY SO
WE SORT OF PAID SOME ATTENTION
TO IT.
>> QUEENS.
BUT IT WASN'T OUR THING.
WE'LL LET THE NEWSPAPERS AND THE
FOLKS ON LONG ISLAND THEY'LL
HAVE THE MAIN PIECE OF IT.
A LOCAL PAPER DID, BUT IT DIDN'T
GET MOVED UP TO SAY, NEWS 12 OR
WHATEVER THE LOCAL CABLE STATION
IS.
>> NEWS 12.
>> AND THEN YOU HAVE THE BIG NEW
YORK AFFILIATES COVERING THE
METRO AREA, ALL OF NEW YORK
CITY, PLUS A PIECE OF LONG
ISLAND.
IT WASN'T ANYBODY IN
PARTICULAR'S JOB IT WAS ONLY
AFTER "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
FOCUSED ON IT, IT JUST HAPPENED
TO BE AFTER THE ELECTION THAT
YOU STARTED TO GET THE
INVESTIGATIVE RESOURCES AND SORT
OF THE BREATH AND THE REACH.
SO THIS IS ANOTHER CHAPTER IN
THE LONG-STANDING TRAGEDY OF THE
COLLAPSE OR DECLINE OF LOCAL
NEWS.
>> IT IS THAT.
BECAUSE THE REALITY IS, YOU
KNOW, ESPECIALLY IN THIS NEWS
ENVIRONMENT, CONGRESSIONAL RACES
ARE RARELY TREATED AS TOP
PRIORITIES, UNLESS THEY ARE
MARQUEE RACES AND THIS IS AN
EXAMPLE WHERE IT FELL THROUGH
THE CRACKS.
I DON'T THINK IT'S A GREAT
EXCUSE FOR ANY OF US, BUT
LARGELY IT'S A DEATH OF LOCAL
MEDIA STORY.
>> WHAT DOES KEVIN McCARTHY DO?
WHAT DO THE REPUBLICANS DO?
>> McCARTHY CONTINUES FOE
CUSHIONING ON KEVIN McCARTHY AND
TRYING TO BECOME THE SPEAK ER.
>> WHOEVER IS SPEAKER HAS TO SAY
SOMETHING.
>> THEY NEED ONE VOTE FROM
GEORGE SANTOS.
>> AND AFTER THAT THEY'RE DONE?
>> NO COMMITTEES, SIT IN THE
CORNER.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> AND TRY TO MARGINALIZE HIM
AND TO YOUR POINT IN TWO YEARS
WE'LL DO IT AGAIN AND I THINK
THE DEMOCRATS WILL APPROACH THE
RACE DIFFERENTLY.
IT'S HARD TO SEE GEORGE SANTOS
SURVIVING A RE-ELECTION,
ASSUMING HE MAKES IT THAT FAR
BUT I THINK BASICALLY THEY TRY
TO LEAVE THIS AS A PROBLEM THEY
DON'T HAVE TO DEAL WITH.
>> DODGE THE REPORTERS, TWO
YEARS OF RUNNING AWAY FROM
REPORTER QUESTIONS.
>> THEY'VE GOTTEN GOOD AT IT.
>> I KNOW.
>> IS IT POSSIBLE FOR HIM TO
HIDE FROM REPORTERS?
>> SANTOS?
>> HE'S TALKED TO A LOT OF OTHER
PEOPLE.
>> WHEN HE'S SEATED HE'S GOING
TO BE WALKING IN THE HALLS.
>> I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE
DIFFERENT.
WHEN YOU GET THE CRUSH OF
REPORTERS WHO ARE, YOU KNOW, ON
YOU AT THAT MOMENT.
I THINK THAT'S --
>> MANU, GOING AFTER YOU WITH
THE MIC.
>> HOW DO YOU -- MY NAME IS
TRENT WILSON AND I'M, YOU KNOW,
JEWISH FROM -- HOW DO YOU -- YOU
JUST MAKE IT UP, I WENT TO
HARVARD, GRADUATED TOP OF MY
CLASS.
IT'S LIKE THE LOVE IT SEGMENT ON
SNL.
>> YES.
CATCH ME IF YOU CAN.
THERE'S A DEGREE IN WHICH PART
OF THE FAILURE IN CATCHING THIS,
IT'S INCONCEIVABLE TO ME THAT A
CANDIDATE LIKE THIS EXISTED,
PROBABLY INCONCEIVABLE TO YOU.
MEDIA OUTLETS STILL DO GIVE
CANDIDATES TO SOME EXTENT
BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT NOT
THINKING EVERYTHING HERE MUST BE
NOT TRUE, SO LET'S POKE AT IT.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.